high drama and 11th hour brinkmanship
not for the first time in the four and a
half year breakup between the uk
and the eu our negotiation teams have
been working
day and night over the recent days
and despite the exhaustion after
almost one year of negotiations and
despite the fact that deadlines have
been missed over and over
we both think that it is responsible at
this point in time
to go the extra mile did the fact that
the two sides hadn't called a halt to
trade negotiations as some had expected
mean that progress was being made no one
was going that far
i do think as i say there is a deal to
be done
if our partners want to do it
but we remain very far apart on these
key
issues and you know what they they are
the uk can't be
locked into the eu's regulatory orbit
uh and we've obviously got to take back
control of our
fisheries uh you know four and a half
years after people uh voted for it
no deadlines been set for this latest
extension of talks frankly there's been
so many deadlines made and missed that
no one would believe it anyway
the only hard date now is the first of
january
by which time these two giant trade
partners will have separated for good
deal or no deal britain intent on
protecting its sovereignty the eu
looking after the interests of its
single market
it is a nail-biting time particularly
for businesses
for whom world trade organization rules
in a no deal scenario
would mean tariffs and quotas raising
the cost of imports and exports
with implications for some sectors that
may struggle to survive
the amount of tax like if it's like 30
percent tax on some cheese you know it's
like
will the people still going to be
afforded and especially after kovids
like you can tell like well the rich are
still rich and the poor
even more poor so trades we don't know
how it's going to be you know boris
johnson's government is adamant britain
will flourish
even without a deal no one it says
should worry
but plenty do jonah al jazeera london